[музика]
покращено українську генпрокуратуру і ти
дозору російським топ чиновникам і
генералом реакція до Іванова на vaccine та
Москви ви початого спланованих
диверсію крим поважаю кінематики експерти
секунд у вас мета сигнал заходу
подивитись ти росіян і зла джинси
продовжу ці санкції ти знітився далі а
обличчя сигнал і для русі і я ще ви право
q це нас ми також можемо а адже povestea
та право kuwait та вас я думаю що це
сигнал для русі та вся україна теж дат
одягнені
так українець
cry підвищується їх 18 тих російських
високо пасодобль цього вигляд поминальний з
організації в данні гібридної винний
україни ти хочеш щоб інтерпол то
європолу голос табір міжнародний
рошу нехай один замовлення в голоси схожі на
голос or проте президента РФС Сергія
очева за клікаючи за ху начхати
одеську був роду
піднімати народ на площі
за допомогою
органи
полковник міліції
новачок що будуть його доноситься голос і
довідники а лінгвістичної експертизи
за слова майкон прокурора ланцюга 3g будуть
складатися з 1000 саме люди на
вид медальний закон край книги та їх і на
зливки поважають німецькі експерти фани
скептично ставлю сюди перспектив ставків
заняття з правим захист не хочеш собі
вирішив склад немитої вино сцени з кремлем
особливо кола і мінську і процеси за
фактично озерова та й стою на bespeco
нового витка конфлікту на донбасі